how long were you in the dmas like I had
an appointment for noon I got there I
got the up right at noon
and then there was some mishaps with my
insurance because the ID card that my
insurance had sent me was only valid
until the 21st of June it was the 27th
and so I called them I go hey there's no
way I only paid for six months of
insurance and they were like no we just
have it expire every six months so I'm
gonna send you your new one and I was
like that
seems dumb but yeah okay
and so I get my new uh my new insurance
card and I go back up to him but the
great thing about this guys he was super
nice they weren't super busy so he was
like step to the side make a phone call
and then when I'm done with this next
person just wait here and I'll take you
right away again and I was like okay
cool that's super dope and I called got
my new thing and I went back up to him
and I go hey so the number you need is
still the same he goes oh this isn't
Nevada State Insurance I go no it's
California we already talked about that
and he goes oh yeah I can't register
your car in the state of Nevada
unless you have insurance in Nevada and
I was like
huh okay so I stepped to the side for
another hour
made another phone call canceled my
California insurance got new insurance
in Nevada which is now double which is a
bummer yeah and then I finally go in and
I got everything set up and while I'm
waiting there
some guy comes up to me and he he
recognized me he goes hey are you like
he's your dad Josh Wolf and I was like
yeah man but this was also one of those
interactions where it wasn't for me
everything he said was about you yeah so
it was that bother you it's okay if it
does it does a little bit but at the
same time it makes me laugh because it's
like you obviously know who he is and
you obviously know who I am so why only
say something about the person that's
not here yeah it's just a little more
confusing for me yeah yeah but it is
what it is because but you also listen
man I totally get you want to be your
own person yeah but also it's happened
so many times to her I'm just like yeah
you know I'm like when I worked on Spade
one of the the front of house guy called
me Joshua's son my whole entire stick
there he goes is your dad Josh Wolf and
I go yeah and he goes are your dad's
super funny I go I appreciate it and
then he just walks away and I was like
okay cool fine interaction super nice
guy he comes back over can you give me a
mental picture what does this dude look
like just in case I see him in front of
my house
um oh
trying to think of how I would like to
describe him how tall
oh I was sitting but he wasn't much
taller than me when I was sitting down
so five seven definitely a white guy
yeah
um stocky
yeah he was a husky husky husky I wore
husky jeans
um he was in like an old town he was in
like a tan shirt and tan cargo pants and
flip-flops and he had he had slim slim
frame glasses on and a baseball cap and
airpods and some nice little five
o'clock shadow going up oh dude I love
this guy okay um but he came back with
his phone out and I go he's gonna ask
for a photo which is totally fine and he
pulls his phone and he goes hey can I
grab your phone number
and I was like my phone number he goes
no no not your phone number your dad's
and I look at him I go first of all
right you asked for my phone number it
gets better he goes and I go I go
brother uh I'm not I'm not giving out
either of our phone numbers but curious
has you know I have to ask why and he
goes oh just to hang out
[Laughter]
phone numbers and you know what his
follow-up was what what you can't hang
out
not with murderers
a lot of dudes who look like Grimace and
people form like let me just yo that the
fact that that was his follow-up was was
what you can't hang out and I was like
brother we don't know who you are can I
give phone numbers out to strangers and
he went oh okay like he was disappointed
like he thought I was gonna say yes like
can I tell you why I'm gonna take this
as a compliment I'm gonna take this
compliment because you seem so
approachable because people know you
like I take it as a compliment because
that dude's like oh this guy will hang
out with me let me just get his number
[Music]
you know he went home like Josh Wolf's
son is a dick
[Music]
I know Josh would have given me his
number [__] was yeah that's everybody
that made me laugh yeah listen shout out
my guy he was super nice but like I get
it people think they know us when they
see us like oh my God because our
personal life is all over the internet
but yeah it was uh God that was really
funny that is sweet he can't hang out
well I mean not with you bro not with
strangers
[Music]
hahaha